Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and take
a look at the newest way to create layered materials in
Unreal. So let's get started. In my slides, you'll see that I
have broken down every single step that you need to take to
be able to make this process work. There are three major
materials that you're going to need. You're going to need a
material layer. You're also going to need a material in
general as a parent material to house everything. And you're
also going to need a material library setup. And in that
material library setup within your material, we need to create
a thing called a blend material. And that blend asset is going
to make it so that we can actually bring the two
materials together. So let's go and jump into Unreal and
feel free to follow along with the slides. And we're
going to break this down so you can see exactly the steps
to make it happen. So in Unreal, we can see that I have
set up here a layered material system. And it says
the new way. I have two different version copies here
that you can actually look at. And they're doing two
different things. One of them is a simple two layer blend.
The other one is a three layer blend. And anytime you
can click on these and crack them open. We're mainly
going to focus on the two layer blend just for
time's sake. But we can also look at this one first
up and see kind of what's going on under the hood. If
I click on this one, let's go and click on the
material here inside the details. So I double click that
let me go and pull this one over. And we'll see
that we actually have the details as well as a layer
parameters. Now we've actually added a while back the
ability to be able to add layers if you need to. And
you can create an instant material layer. And in here
connect the materials that maybe you've already built.
You'll see a plus sign for that here. Down below, we
see that we have an ice material took a while to
populate, but it got in there. And this ice material
is our layer asset. In this particular case, you'll see
that ml is underneath because I've made this into a
material layer. I'll show you how to do that in just
a bit. And down below, we have several different
areas from which everything's are popping, everything is
populated. We'll see under our subsurface area, which
is built within the ice, we have a subsurface amount
and a subsurface color which is exposed. But in
there, we also have an MLB which is a material layer
blend. This material layer blend allows these other
materials such as this one on the top, and this
one on the bottom to all actually blend together. And
you'll see there is one more here at the bottom
also. So these allow us to be able to actually have
three different layers of materials in here. And
really, the key is these material layer blends, if
they're in place, they're going to allow everything
to come together. Now we're going to do this more in
a simpler aspect or simple way, we're going to go
ahead and tackle this with a more simple here, I'm
clicking on the one from behind back here. And
this one, if we get to our layer properties, we're
going to be building the material in this
particular case. Now I made a couple in here in
the default that have pop populated, and they're
not actually going to do anything. So we can
actually get rid of them. Or you can keep them if
you want to and throw some stuff in there later.
But we're going to first build our material
layers one, and two. And then we're going to
make a single material layer blend. And they're
going to cause these guys to actually blend
together. So how it's going to look if we went in
here and play with it, and I'll keep this
material instance open, you can actually see I
have an area underneath our scalar parameter
values. I haven't grouped this one, but you get
the idea of grouping, we can go in here and I
can contrast it, pull up the contrast, and you'll
see the details of the damage come through. If I
go to intensity, I can see that I can actually
completely get rid of it and make the tile come
through from the bottom. This is really
convenient and helpful. And that's pretty much
what we're going to build. So let's go and jump
right in and do so. Alright, so let's go ahead
and build our first material. So I'm going to go
to the class folder here. And I'm going to
create a folder called demo, I can see I have
one already made. But feel free to just right
click and create a new folder. That's just to
keep things up, up and running here. And we're
going to make a new one called ml underscore new
tile, and then ml is for material layer. Now if
you're not sure to get there, you simply right
click in here, go to materials, and you should
know this by now to get to the erroneous stuff.
But I'll point it to you because you know,
some things sometimes you can forget. So under
materials, you go down here and you go to
layer material, we're going to make two of
these. So let's go and make another one. So I'm
going to go to ml underscore, this one's going
to be the new grunge. There we go. And then
we need to make a material blend. So we can
actually get that done ahead of time. So let's
go in here, go to materials. And we're going
to go to material layer blend. Now I'm going to
go and click on this. And we do have a few that
are already built in, you'll see them, material
layers ready to go. So you could use those if
you wanted to, but we're going to make our own
in this particular case. So you can get an idea
on how this works. So we'll do mlb from material
layer blend. And we'll call this a demo. Or
we'll just say new demo. There we go. And
then finally, we need a parent material, we're
going to house all of this. And I'll show you
how to build it. Now this is going to be broken
up probably in several videos. We don't want
this to run too long. But I want to get the
foundation ready for you. So you can actually
jump back to it when you need to. So we're
going to go to materials here. And we're
just going to simply go to material and you
can also go here at the top. And this is
going to be our parent material. So we'll say
m underscore demo, parent, here you go, you
can call it whatever you want, whatever works
for you. Let's go and double click on the
tile first, pop that up. It's off screen. So
let me pull that over. And let me open this
up. So you can actually see what's going on
here. Now we can keep that preview going,
that's totally fine to be able to do so. So
don't think that you have to actually mess
with that. But you know, you can leave it
that way you can kind of see your texture
unfolding as you're working. So what we're
going to need here is a make material
attributes. And that's going to plug into
this guy here who looks and kind of acts
like a function input. And we've talked
about that in other classes. Let's go full
screen here and move this back. I'm gonna
leave my stats open. But if there's any
errors, it will pop up automatically. If
you need more real estate, feel free to
close that. That's totally fine. I just
did anyway. So that's fine. We'll just
leave that closed. It'll let us know if
we plug things in correctly. So let's go
and create a make material attributes. So
do make material attributes. So this is
going to give us a foundation so we
actually can customize this material any
way that we want acts like an override
and allows us to, you know, build
anything that we need. So I'm gonna
pull this execution string into my
preview here for my material. In here,
I'm going to go ahead and create or
call up my tiles. So I'm gonna go
ahead and hit the T key, left click
and T. So let's do that. T left click
and there we go. And we're going to
go ahead and call up the texture that
we need in this particular case, this
texture that we're choosing is going to
be a reflection tiles. So let's go and
do T underscore reflection tiles. There
we go. And we'll hit the T key again,
we're going to need the normals. And
you can actually punch in whatever you
want. Hey, in subsurface in the case
of the ice, we had a subsurface
texture we can use. And we'll do
again reflection. And we want to do
underscore. There's the broken down
normals. Cool, got that set up. And we
in this particular case, we can go
straight into the normals. Now, if you
wanted to, you can allow elaborate
this a little bit more, we can go
ahead and that's always good to do
convert to parameter, because then it's
going to show up normals tiles, it's
going to show up in our instance, we
make it and we'll put that in here
and we can keep it simple. We'll just
do multiply, we won't do a flat
normal and a minus one minus in that
particular case, we really don't need to
invert this, it's pretty
straightforward. So I'm gonna come and
figure out the ASCII and we'll just
say normal strength. Can't spell
today. There we go. Normal strength
and we'll keep that as one. We're
going to lock that down. So let's
keep this down to a maximum five, we
can put it in a group if we want to
so we can just type in normal and
you should know this by now how to do
so. We can do the same thing with
this guy here. With him exposed, we can
set him to normal. Also, here we got
the albedo so we can control the
intensity of that if we want to. So
just hit the multiply again, M and
left click. And we're going to go
ahead and hit the three constants.
Now in my sample, it has a four
constant, you're going to get an
error, but I won't tell you what
the error is, which is kind of
annoying. So you know, at one point,
it did work. He's a four constant.
In our particular case, we don't
need that extra alpha information. So
we can keep it a three constant. So
I'm going to right click here, and
we'll say convert to a parameter. And
we'll call this albedo tint. There
we go. And we'll set that to a
white because that works better
with multiplying. If it's add, we
can adjust that to a darker tone.
Put that in the B channel, put
this in the A channel. And then
we'll drag this into the base
color, grab the normal put into
the A channel, put the scaler into
the B channel, and grab that
input into the normal. And there
we go, we have this initial
one set up. Cool. So in the next
video, we're going to go and
build the other material layer.
And we're going to go ahead and
elaborate on what we have. And
then we're going to bring these
all together with a material
layer blend. Thanks again.